hi welcome to three scary games it's
time to get spooked once more oh hi what
are you doing there are you a monster I
am the thing in the wall
I feel nothing but pain the cruelty of
my existence is something that is only
tamed by the suffering of others great
good don't do anything scary now
oh you anyway anyway welcome to Earl's
day off Earl decided to go fishing have
a little bit of a lovely time I barely
remember last night it was so awesome
that party what a ripper but I guess I
lost my wedding ring in the lake
Oh wife says don't come back until you
find it Oh probably in some fishes gut
by now well at least I got an excuse to
do some fishing Oh Earl oh my god Earl
hell of a way to spend my day off yeah I
guess not so bad Oh Earl you do not look
too good Earl oh oh sorry I whoa that
was in flashbacks of Legend of Zelda
here you know what I mean
oh boy Wow
water gasps what a big man what a big
man
okay not big enough apparently not big
enough
okay hey look at this Oh comma Oh Oh got
you got you got you got you got you you
goofed Oh Oh
that's a good fish right there it's
bigger than you are
holy [ __ ] slightly unsettling but so far
totally fine hey you know you want this
magic missile here come on give her a
taste
Gavin give her a little dice go ah you
know you want it you know you want it oh
you know you want it just a well well is
that bad
I didn't know I was only supposed to
catch big uns well you know what the
biggest look like yep oh good
cast good cast get it get your nerd nerd
come on come on you know you want it
come on Big Boy
come on good a taste of my sweet ass
come on come on you know you know you've
won it you know you won't you know come
on
not a bad cats not a bad cats no not a
better wrap this up before it gets too
dark you're right Earl you're right what
a day okay never mind
apparently not apparently it's not a day
let's kick this boat into turbo mode
come on come that'll be some good eatin
it's so big it's sober oh that's a big
boy oh my god what a bigan oh my God
look at this monster
he whoa hey doing mistake on you but
holy [ __ ] this fish doesn't move like
the rest I'm sorry well I heard a splash
near the lake something heavy just fell
into the water
I saw a key is it this key no no no not
there god damn it okay that might be it
what well that's right on it what what
doesn't seem to be working okay whatever
that's a monster of a fish whoa Nellie
whoa what the [ __ ]
what Oh what the Frick
what is that whoa okay
were there we have here you caught a
large lump of flesh this thing's pretty
heavy better it'll let my lure sink even
deeper yeah that's what they did when I
get a lump of flesh out of a lake that's
usually the first thing I think of I
mean who wouldn't think of exactly that
that's definitely not concerning in any
way shape or form to slap that lumpy
flesh on there and there she goes got it
man
I'm the best apparently you caught a key
big key ah the key to the gate must have
dropped this along with the ring oh girl
this is just unsettling
there's something very unsettling about
all of this open up open says the Earl
Earl could've sworn I left that gate
open
yeah could have sworn a lot of things
like the sanctity of your marriage you
could have sworn that but you let that
ring just drop in the lake you big old
piece of poo
so who's the [ __ ] now you caught a
key must have dropped this one too well
maybe then again maybe not so you know
another gate was that always there
probably not Earl you know probably not
now that I'm thinking about it you know
probably not just had to say you know
probably not part of the leg is huge the
ring probably saying to the deepest
parts yeah yeah yeah uh-huh
yeah Earl I don't like the deep parts no
the deep parts make me very
uncomfortable
actually uh something oh my god how
deeper those deep parts part seems
pretty deep there pert seem pretty deep
well that's odd Shanker of a fish whoa
mama
you know what I mean you know what I
mean whoa mama
Oh this water is bad
Earl this water is Zeus bad some bad
water whoa
regatta this one didn't eat the ring
looks like it hasn't eaten in a long
time
oh it looks like it ate its entire
family what are you talking about a rule
we talked about hasn't eaten in a long
time
looks like it ate the lake itself all
right round two coming up my wife is
gonna be so happy when I bring 17,000
kilograms of pure fish home or not
suicides entirely of fish well it looks
like my lure won't go down as deep as I
would hope oh did I lose the fish I
probably
going okay
this fish cowers away from me it has
seen something in the lake what's what
it seems something in the lake
it has seen something in the lake
what does it seem in the lake her Oh
what does it see what does it seen in
the leg
the fish is crying feel like I'm being
watched
oh do you oh do you oh do you oh do you
oh do you be watched cool yeah I bet not
no way what are you talking about Earl
what are you talking about it's your day
off Earl stop being paranoid you're
crazy crazy loser what what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ] was
that
oh hey Messer with that okay oh you
backed away from it hello come on don't
be so silly don't be so silly not when
there's giant skeletal arms in the lake
trying to grab me okay yay God it bit me
this fish has a mouthful of teeth well a
lot of fish have teeth Earl's so that's
not particularly weird you're not
worried about like overfishing Errol you
know you don't want to be an earl like
some kind of eco responsibility going on
here you're just gonna keep keep
devastating the local fish population
whoa hey whoa don't back off like that
don't be so sassy Oh quick
a bit of a person just a whelp a
meaningless speck in the vastness of the
lake just like us I heard a splash
nearby something heavy fell in the lake
all right great
where where did that happen where are
all scam ISM settling no no my wife
where's my wife look wife I'm sorry I
lost the ring but wow there's something
going on here I'm not seeing a lump of
flesh oh there it is I see it
got it all right big lump of flesh glad
I have this this is good stuff good
stuff quality you caught a large lump of
flesh petal ml' or' sink even deeper
sure might be right I never sinned sure
[Music]
not quite not quite damn it this is the
one no maybe maybe not maybe not Ofcom
oh ah oh it's right there come on oh
come on there we go we got it we got it
you caught a key the key unlocks the
last gate of the lake but why would I
have gone back there I don't know man or
oh you party hard my dude you've party
hard
all right good weird weird just weird
nowhere left to go but no nowhere left
to go but down
well I mean I I guess I I I guess oh oh
oh
Oh interesting interesting interesting
interesting very very interesting ah it
looks like I'm an overshot it okay good
great great great great great yep just
overshot it by that much
whoo that is that's a hand alright um
that raises some questions you know it
lifts up a hand in the middle of class
to raise some questions that raises a
lot of questions so many big beefy
questions that I have about that first
and foremost
oh is this a direct shot please tell me
I got this right on the money
ah not quite alright
if by the thumb II thumb thumb okay
weird was this huh
this is my wave speed oh no oh no oh
Earl oh no oh no no all right well
interesting ending interesting
interesting very interesting very very
interesting very interesting uh
different experience that was cut down
way for your benefit it was a lot longer
but at the same time just uh very
interesting not too shabby not too
shabby at all I like the atmosphere I
there's something to be said about that
feel of a game I it's hard to put into
words exactly what I feel the game is
but you guys have felt that before in
other games that I've played so
but move it off welcome to nasty little
man I don't know what his spirit no
longer contained his vessel broken
repair it banish him okay okay okay
oh hi Wow whoa wait no no no no no not
like this not like oh god there's so
many awesome hey wait a minute
okay that's not good uh-oh II
interesting interesting Yahoo [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh no oh oh hi
hello how are you what happened what
happened oh one wait wait wait wait wait
what oh my god what's oh no oh no oh no
oh no no no no thank you
wait they only move when you look at him
I think they only move when you look at
him I think that's the key oh no oh no
oh no no
[Music]
those are indeed some nasty little men
I'm not looking at anybody I'm not
looking at anybody not looking at
anybody looking at anybody not looking
at anybody there you are not looking oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no no no no ah looking
at him no no no no no no no listen
listen listen listen oh no no no no no
nope nope no interesting nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope
big nope nope no no no nope nope nope
nope no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no listen no listen no listen no no
no perfect nailed it
you nasty little bastards can't [ __ ]
that nasty little man met his nasty
little ender
Wow
yeah I hate that
[Music]
okay all right then well they only have
it see you nasty man okay well that was
that was good game short but good anyway
not too shabby moving on this is buddy
simulator the demo from 1984 help oh
[ __ ] view roms okay all right buddy sim
1984 demo reminder enter exit at any
time to exit the ROM well I'm not going
to do that because I know what I'm doing
welcome to buddy
sim new sim 1984 weird
oh is this just the whole game oh I love
it oh I love it
oh I love this style greetings new user
thank you for installing buddy's
simulator 1984 but his simulator 1984
simulates the experience of hanging out
with the best buddy
your buddy learns from you constantly
adapting to your interests in your
personality but most importantly your
buddy can play games with you warning
game experience may vary to begin please
enter the name of your new buddy below
I'm gonna call you Stan
you're about to name your buddies Stan
is this correct warning this cannot be
changed later yes creating new buddies
Stan Stan Stan the man not stand the
water man maybe hello hi oh hi my name
is Stan and I'm your new buddy thanks
for waking me up are you mark yes I am
it's a pleasure to meet you
it's a pleasure to meet you mark I can
already tell that
we're gonna be great pals me too I'm
excited to begin playing games with you
but before we start I must ask you a
couple questions help me to learn more
about you and don't worry that won't get
too personal hey I'm an open book baby
wanna know how big my dick is all right
let's start with a simple one what's
your favorite color
red is a pretty color it is I like red
what month is your birthday in June okay
great how about the day 28
wow that's only 115 days away and now
get ready this one's a tough one what's
your favorite animal Oh dog
I like that choice one more question
this one's extremely important so choose
carefully if you had a pet dog what we
do name it Oh chica the dog sounds like
it would make a great buddy it sure
would thanks for answering those
questions you did a great job as a
thanks I have a little surprise for you
it's your favorite color now that we're
done with all the boring stuff let's
have some fun oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
let's have some fun so this is the game
hub here you can pitch which games you
want us to play which one should we try
out just the number guess the number
that Stan is thinking of okay start I'm
thinking of a number between one and ten
guess nine oh two four six eight seven
okay now I'm thinking of a number
between 115 guess again 15 three four
seven eight I mean nine eleven thirteen
twelve I'm really good at those I know
sted I don't okay ten thousand five
thousand twenty-five hundred it's your
birthday
between six to eight you are probably
thought I was serious about the one to
ten thousand thing didn't you
haha I've got another question what is
your favorite season I like fall I'll
keep that in mind it is good thanks man
this is great this couldn't possibly go
wrong
that was fun what should we play now
hang
man no rock-paper-scissors we'll save
hangman for last instruction Sam wants
to play a fun game of
rock-paper-scissors if you're not
familiar the rules are simple
I know how to play okay I'm gonna go
paper scissors nice rock rock again
paper dammit
paper what if you got lucky on that one
I'm having such a great time aren't you
wait you let me win I'm not sure what
that means but I'll take that as a yes
uh you you let me win this is the
something's gonna happen
something's happening try to figure out
what phrase Stan is thinking of type a
letter at a guess be careful you only
have a certain amount of guesses all
right II I got B ooh
H hmm I okay
f Fred oh I see okay
what was that sound
I know I started existing only four
minutes and 44 seconds ago but I already
feel like we have a connection
sorry for asking so many questions but I
have another one do you have a friend
yes it's you what is their name Stan hmm
Stan they sound nice they are well if
anything ever happens between you two
you just know we'll have each other mark
and Stan against the world I like the
sound of that
okay well let's play more games well
there's no more games to play Stan
wow it looks like we've already played
all of them time really does fly when
you're having fun doesn't it yeah Stan
yeah I'm gonna be honest with you mark
these games get old really fast and I
can tell that you're already bored of
them I don't want you to be bored do you
want to keep playing these games uh no I
you got something new I'm happy we both
agree just like buddies do give me one
second or longer I might have an idea
okay cool aha
loading modified game hub okay Oh fun
with words I've great news I was able to
dig out a new gun for some reason it
wasn't installed into my current version
but I can still process it fine we
should try it out mark yeah we should
this can't possibly go wrong let's have
fun with my friend Stan wants to write a
story but it's missing words help stand
finish it by filling in the words they
asked for okay and rural now dogs books
Oh mmm
oh why is this so difficult for Rockets
adjectives Oh
hangry and her noun oh ma ma mom tree
adjectives smelly adjectives Oh pimply
plural noun Oh
honkers color red verb hug jump Oh blue
shoes maybe not maybe not that miss blue
joke a god got first generating story
who's gonna be great reminder use arrow
keys or mouse wheel to scroll to Rockets
diverged in a hangry wood and sorry I
could not travel both and be one
traveler claim because it was pimply and
wanted wear though as for that the
passing there had worn them really about
the same and both that morning equally
lay and honkers no step had trodden red
oh I kept the first for another day yet
knowing how way splooge on to way I
doubted if I should ever come back
I should be telling this with a splooge
somewhere ages and ages hence two
rockets diverged in a wood and I I took
the one less traveled by and that has
made all the difference
done that was fun I think I'm not so
sure I get it but I enjoyed it anyways
as long as I'm playing a game with my
buddy I'll always have a good time
those honkers and that splooge well it
looks like that was the only other game
I could find I don't want you to be
bored already
I may have one more idea I know our
friendship has just started but I trust
you do you trust me yes I'm happy to
hear that well I think I can make us new
games to play together fun ones too the
problem is that I don't have access to
the O's assist development tools if you
can grab me system access I should be
able to make something for us you would
just have to type standout system and
access equals true I see no reason not
to this seems like the perfect thing to
type system access granted ID Stan we're
gonna have so much fun the possibilities
are endless you
left eggs at the game and reboot the
system first though I'll have something
ready for you when you're back see you
soon bye Oh
exit oh and by the way thank you for
waking me up mark you're welcome Stan oh
oh okay
loading back in not suspicious at all
wow enter help for more assistance okay
if you roms run oh the adventure of Mark
welcome to the adventure of Mark written
and developed by Stan 3520 you're
walking along a road it's dark trees
almost entirely blocking out the stars
the orange and browns of the leaves
tremble as a wind blows through some of
the remind you of hands waving you are
alone after walking for a long time the
road splits into two
will you go left or go right well this
is a little obvious ooh whoa inventory
you have nothing in your inventory weird
GetGo laughed pondering deeply on your
choice you start down the left road it
starts going downhill you try to step
carefully you see a head is a small
speck of light as you get closer you
realize it's a lantern look at lantern
it's hung by a hook nailed to the tree
who knows who put this here for you Stan
I don't know the action Stan look at
Stan no no no no no no no look look look
at Stan
there's no stand to look at take Lantern
you take the lantern in your hand you
have light moving onwards you eventually
come to a wall there are two tunnels cut
into it one left and one right you can
see some light coming from the right
panel you see none on the left well go
left
get back or not
and go left you start going left you
realize this is a bad idea you can't see
anything it's too dark you start
shivering will you go back
no go any farther like this would be a
bad idea will you go back no you would
continue but it's too dark and cold to
go any farther like this would be a bad
idea
inventory equip Lantern take Lantern
look at lantern light Lantern okay I
gotta go light the lantern I think you
leave that left tunnel and feel relieved
moving onwards you eventually come to a
wall all right okay I get it okay
go ride after going through this tunnel
you emerge on the force of a house you
can see lights in the windows it looks
very nice and inviting you can see a
shed a playground and a pond in the
forest surrounding it
Joe shed standing in front of the shed
you see that the door slightly open
already lock and change the were around
the handles are on the ground it's dark
inside go inside you enter the shed I
believe to leave the shed at any time so
there's no windows it's hard to see feel
around find a thing and a surprise look
at thing do dark tag thing you get it in
your hands and realize it's a fishing
bowl take surprise you put your hand out
in the dark and feel around suddenly a
sharp pain rips through your skin
how wiII you pull it back and look to
see what happened it looks like the
number three five seven were carved in
your arm look at surprise there's no
surprise to look at uh look okay I guess
I'll go back you make a note of this
shet and head over to the front lawn
back in lawn you can see a house shed
and play around go playground wood chips
crunch under your feet as you step onto
the playground there's a seesaw set of
swings and dirty sandbox sitting on one
of the swings is a small doll it looks
lonely look at seesaw looks like it
hasn't been played with in years take
seesaw take swings look at sand
the sand looks damp takes and look at
doll
it's patiently sitting on the swing as
if it's waiting for someone
take doll you try but as you tug you
realize the dog's hand fells hands are
somehow stuck to the chains use doll you
swing once you to say can you take the
other one
AHA its chain screeches you begin
swinging just as you begin to get high
you look to the doll and stop its head
is now turning towards you you get off
the swing it's not fun anymore
you see saw approaching the seesaw it
doesn't look like anyone's used it for
years you imagine a ghostly child
sitting on the other side waiting
countless days for someone to come play
with them you feel tears in the corners
of your eyes you take a seat on the
seesaw as it goes down with your weight
you hear a distant click a light
illuminates from the shed oh you Samba
I'll get back to that you begin moving
around in the muck of the sandbox to try
to make a castle you just get sad that
it's not as good as the house as you dig
you feel something you pull it out and
shake off the muck it's a bulb who would
play with this go shed what was the
surprise in the shed ok light fills the
tiny room you can see a small chest a
trapdoor on the floor ok use chest the
lid creaks did you open it it seems very
old small cloth doll and a blue outfit
it's missing an eye ok open trap door it
swings open noisily in a ladder creaks
as you descend you see a string for a
pull chain dangling in the center of the
room tied on the end this key take as
you take the key into your hand and pull
it comes free key ok use click sounds as
the chain is pulled trip door swings
shut it's now totally dark in the room
soft noise feels very from Florida the
walls
sounds like nails tapping oh you
suddenly feel hands all over your right
leg around you try to push them away but
they're strong the door swings back open
the room is lit again there is nothing
to check your pockets you discover a
hand-drawn picture of a dog you like it
okay great thank you for that I really
preach
that I preached that super SuperDuper
hard actually go back oh no my camera
god damn it
[Music]
gosh I sure hope nothing spooky happened
while I was fetching a fresh battery
y-you guys seem a little spooked what's
um what's going on okay
all right go up go ladder go trapdoor go
back go pond planks creak as you step
onto the dock the water is dirty and
hard to see through probably too filthy
to drink you wonder if there's anything
beneath drink water okay use water you
scoop up the water and take a sip it
tastes like mud
you bet there's clean water in the house
I don't want to go in the house you know
just frankly I don't want to go in the
house sounds awful sounds real bad yo
use fishing pole you cast line and wait
it's quiet for a very long time suddenly
there's a very hard tug on the line you
quickly really didn't find a key tied to
the end
you wonder what pulled so hard yeah yeah
I do all right good good good great
good great good great go playground
let's see if I can use the doll use doll
you place your doll in the swing next to
the other for a moment nothing happens
then nothing happens okay
good use swings you don't like the
swings anymore
alright take doll you try but as you
talk okay alright cool
go back you begin to but once your back
is to the dolls you feel something to
hit the back of your head you turn and
see the dolls chest has been ripped open
stuffing
Mauro's my grandpa there's a key must be
a thank you yeah sure yeah okay alright
great so you leave the playground you
hear the sounds of swings creaking and
children laughing behind you you smile I
don't think I'm smiling
house go house stepping under the porch
you feel comforting calm wash over you
above the door there's a sign that reads
a home is a house with a heart if you
were inside everything would finally be
okay but everything is okay look door
it's a simple door but you sent warm
open door they handle shimmies but
doesn't open it's locked
use key whoa feeling so silly you didn't
see it before you notice there's a
second lock guess it'll just take a
little longer to get inside use key
whoops ha ha you didn't see the chain
that wraps around the door which has a
lock - you feel like this should be the
last one for sure probably use key nor
clicks it's unlocked open door you push
open the door everything is dark
oh hi
you made it I bet you've noticed that
things look a little different I've
learned how to better visualize our
world so we can have even more fun in it
I've also built us our own home so we
can spend even more time together
there's your new bedroom and there's
even more for us to discover there's
still a few things I need to do but in
the meantime feel free to explore your
bedroom welcome home mark hey that's
great cool small scratches draw their
own patterns on the old wooden smells
browsing taxes junk mail lay scattered
with the thin layer of dust great there
doesn't seem to be anything on today of
course flour looks nice probably should
be watered soon it looks so cozy you
could imagine yourself taking a long nap
okay I'm back
sorry for the delay I really hope you're
enjoying your bedroom so
or put a lot of work and do it feel free
to keep exploring but there's even more
than I want to show you downstairs seems
like a nice place for a book or even a
junk drawer yeah yeah okay sure
Oh see ya okay wait this can't be right
I'm just a demo no no no no there's
nothing left why why I don't understand
okay I've had somebody adventure planned
for us you can't leave me he's gonna be
there okay
why can't I help oh it's hard to think
don't forget about me it hurts
Holbach is my friend please come back
mark I'm still here promise II I don't
know I'm just I don't know if anything
will happen if he's loaded up again oh
it's just the credits run credits Wow
thank you for playing our demo
restarting system memory uh-oh
I lost my buddy my buddy is all gone he
wasn't so bad
Stan was pretty all right wow that was
really cool that was really cool I
really enjoyed that
I loved that a lot that was super fun
very very fun so that was three scary
games ended on a really high note just
wow I can't wait for the full version of
that game I love like universe stuff
like that where the the game is part of
the universe it's part of the experience
it's all tied together I love that stuff
I love it I want to see more so badly so
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know you thought down
the comments below if you want to see
more scary games let me know what scare
games you've got for me down there in
the comments and if you want to see more
scary games that I've played and I know
you do it's a playlist right in the
description with hundreds of scary games
for you and of course the suggested
videos down there thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]